hey youtubers it's Charlie since it's
been a while since I've done a Legend of
Korra book 3 update I thought it was
time to do a nice long video to help get
you guys excited for 2014 because
there's a lot of stuff happening next
year so here are 9 big things that we
need to talk about number 1 when are we
gonna get to see a book 3 trailer and
when are we gonna see new artwork in
February every year Nickelodeon does up
fronts that's where they show clips from
all their programs to advertisers so
they'll give them money from a practical
standpoint this is Nickelodeon's most
important event all year long so this
will be the first time anyone gets to
see any real footage for book 3
unfortunately because most of us are not
advertisers we will not be able to go to
that event usually the first time the
regular people get to see new clips from
Korra is it their press events in May
that's where big news outlets and
bloggers are invited to see footage and
learn about the new seasons directly
from the creators of all their shows
personally I might have a chance to get
into that press event after that it's
really Comic Con where they show off new
clips but you might not have to worry
because number two Legend of Korra book
3 will premiere much earlier in the year
than book 2 because they started
production on book 3 right after they
wrapped production on book 2 they have a
big head start as of New York Comic Con
this year in October they said they were
about halfway done animating book 3 the
sooner they finished the sooner they can
air it they can even start airing the
first episodes of book 3 before the last
couple are finished being animated
but because the majority of Korra's
audience is younger most shows like
Korra as well as other Nickelodeon shows
premiere either late in the spring or
early in the summer if you remember book
1 premiered in April so conservative
estimate you will be seeing book 3
episode 1 either by June or possibly as
soon as April number 3 if they finish
airing all of book threes episodes
before Comic Con 2014 what are they
going to do their panel this is easy
they're gonna talk all about book 4 they
won't even be close to finishing
animation on book 4 by next summer but
they will have had enough time to cut a
trailer so even though their comic-con
panel next year will cover a lot of the
aftermath of what happens during book 3
they will also be teasing a lot of book
for details remember last year at Comic
Con they aired the entire first episode
of book 2 I don't expect them to do the
same thing again or air to the first
episode of book 4 during Comic Con this
year but I will be sitting in the crowd
just
case number four one of the biggest
changes coming in Legend of Korra book 3
the biggest changes are mostly the
addition of the spirits to the physical
realm and the locations Republic City
will still be a part of book 3 but
because Korra will be travelling to the
earth Kingdom for most of the story it
won't be featured quite as much the
biggest change there is all the spirit
wilds that will be growing from those
vines that the dark avatar guru when he
invaded during the finale
those big vines you saw this is gonna be
like homes for spirits I wonder how much
rent they get charged number 5 what are
those earth Kingdom locations that we're
gonna be visiting I already did a video
about how book 3 is going to be all
about the earth Kingdom but the actual
cities we're going to see will be
bossing sang and possibly Omashu I'm
also holding out hope for Kyoshi Island
but the big issue with Legend of Korra
is that it's only 13 episodes unlike
last airbender which had twice as many
episodes so it's most likely that we
will only be visiting Ba Sing se we
probably won't even get to see Omashu
Koon yetsko and DiMartino did confirm
that there is an earth Queen tullu be
part of the book 3 story so obviously
she's going to be in Ba Sing se so
that's where most of the story will take
place number 6 who is that earth Queen
nothing is confirmed but the best theory
is that it's Alyson Stoner who's playing
a character named opal she originally
confirmed she was voicing a character
before book to premiere but it looks
like her character was intended to be a
major part of book 3 since opal is a
type of precious gem it's likely that
she is actually playing royalty a lot of
the character names on Last Airbender as
well as Korra kind of flow from
character traits just like Azula and
blue fire the other possibility is that
opal could also be a Kyoshi warrior but
I think that's a bit of a long shot even
though the story will be totally new
just like previous books of Korra you
can always expect certain last airbender
themes to come back remember Kouhei was
being manipulated by longfang so it's
possible that the earth Queen could be a
young Queen being manipulated by someone
else and Korra will have to help her out
but number 7 what's up with the beifongs
one of the major subplots will revolve
completely around Lin and her family the
only glimpse we've gotten of top during
Legend of Korra has been in flashback
she's dead in present day and it leaves
this large unexplored issue of Lin's
father the three best theories I've seen
are the Duke a new character we've never
met or she's adopted and we'll never
know who her father is the creators have
already said
that we're going to learn about lin
beifong's parents in this book so I
don't think she's adopted but I do like
the idea that her father is someone
who's connected to the larger plot of
book three even though he might not be
the big bill and himself
number eight why have they waited so
long to talk about Lin's parents and
don't forget Toph was one of the
founding members of Republic City with
Aang and what did all of aunts children
say about Aang is a father during book 2
he was not a super attentive dad which
is probably the case for Lin and Toph
this just means that she's gonna have a
lot of mother or father issues that
she's going to be dealing with in book 3
but I do like the idea that the BEI Fong
family being so big and prominent has a
lot of issues that we'll learn about -
but number 9 who is the villain we don't
have any confirmation on who the big bad
will be we didn't even learn about vaatu
in the dark avatar until book 2 it aired
but what if the medium bad the Varrick
of book 3 turned out to be Lin's father
what's the biggest reason to never talk
about your parents they did something
terrible
the other big possibility is is that the
villain is the character the great de
lisle is playing she announced she was
playing a dark character but since we
didn't see her during book 2 it's likely
we'll see that character during book 3
full disclaimer she is definitely not
playing Azula I know a lot of you are
holding out for Anna's ulla cameo
because technically she's still alive in
present day but just like a lot of other
classic characters if you see her again
it'll probably be in the comic books so
a lot of you've asked me to do a core
version of my ask emergency Q&A videos
so be sure to send me your big questions
in the comments below and subscribe to
get that video I'll probably be doing it
after the holidays I have a lot of
Doctor Who and a lot of Sherlock to get
through next week I'm also gonna be
posting a couple more videos tonight
kind of explaining how that's gonna work
right now click here to get my preview
for book 3 and click here to get my top
10 moments from book - thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
[Music]